giving that moment of acknowledgement
before giving a response especially when
you get into like an argument or like a
heated discussion still like back and
forth back and forth my turn to talk my
turn to talk my turn you know giving
that person honor first of all hey i i
hear you i i completely understand what
you're saying
i feel this way just that small like
acknowledgement of like their their
feelings
letting them know that i heard you i
wasn't just
thinking in my head about how i'm gonna
respond to you and cuss you out right
now i actually listen to you that
changes
how we communicate a lot he's just kind
of like brushing it off but then like
after all he's like
i think i'm gonna stop watching porn we
decided like okay we're gonna do it with
porn we're not doing it anymore we're
not giving into that culture
and that's when we really got deep into
that like spiritual path and like
focusing on each other and that intimacy
and sex on like a spiritual level and
it's it's next level and one thing i
feel like we should focus on more is
connection our culture and
the united states it's like fast paced
go to work and make money and go to work
and come home and be tired and cook
dinner you know it's really hard to
foster connections like we said earlier
it's hard to foster connection with your
spouse if you have more than one child
like oh my god you know making time for
one to build a bond and connection with
that child and to taking
time even in moments of like frustration
even like in moments of like pressure
and forget
everything else and everybody else and
just focus on that little like soul that
you brought into the world children are
going to model what we do before they do
what we say
[Music]
that was destiny bennett an author
speaker content creator parenting coach
educator and wife and mother to three
boys her life's work and purpose
resolves around her journey through and
connection to motherhood and
relationships and she's passionate about
helping others foster authentic
connection with their children and
restore their marriages she uses every
life-changing lesson she's learned
through her marriage her business and
her own self-discovery as an opportunity
to pour into others who can resonate
i find destiny so inspiring and love all
the content she shares so be sure to
follow her on instagram at they call me
mama bennett and you can get her book
revised not repeated a brown mom's guide
to breaking generational curses in
parenting linked below in the show notes
and description box this conversation is
packed with practical tips and life
experiences to implement in your own
life destiny shares her marriage secrets
that helped restore their marriage that
was once greatly suffering after all
they've gone through ways that couples
can make time for intimacy when life is
so busy how porn was destroying their
marriage healthy communication tips and
navigating arguments and disagreements
with your partner how to change toxic
generational patterns in parenting
respecting your child's individuality
fostering authentic connection over
punishment and so much more
both your relationship with your partner
and your relationship with your children
are intertwined because how we model our
relationship with our partner teaches
our children how to be in relation with
others and respecting one another
extends not only to your partner but to
your kids as well
i hope you find this conversation as
enlightening and inspiring as i did
welcome to the ellen fisher podcast
welcome to the podcast destiny thank you
for being here thank you for having me
i have admired your work for a while now
i don't even remember how i came across
your content but i think maybe someone
reposted an instagram reel of yours or
something and it was a video clip
of you getting down on your knee and
talking to your child one of your
children maybe your male child yeah when
he was struggling with something
emotionally and you were sharing tips on
how to help your child manage their
emotions in a supportive way that
teaches them guides them and helps them
feel loved through it and i just like
instantly fell in love with what you
were sharing because you gave you do
something different i think than a lot
of like respectful parenting type of
content creators because you're sharing
like exact
tips on individual situations right you
know like a lot of books are very um
generalized like philosophical which is
all really helpful too but a lot of
times it's like okay but now what what
do i do with my kids screaming what do i
do when this is happening this actual
moment in this actual moment and so
i found that really practical
and really helpful so i'm excited to dig
into it yeah thank you so much i i
i love i love what i do i love being
able to share and i get that a lot that
that's like the aspect that people like
is that like
i actually show what the moments look
like and i feel like that's helpful like
from my viewpoint because i'm a visual
person like i need to see it i can hear
it i can try to apply it but i just feel
like it's easier to like see it so
yeah i'm i'm super excited to get into
it yeah and i also want to talk to you
about like intentional marriage too and
i know it's a lot of the content you
share too which is really helpful
because
especially in the young parenting years
is when it's easy to let go
of the you know the important aspect of
your relationship with your partner
right
so all the stuff that you share combined
i feel like so synchronistic so before i
get into like specific questions what
led you to becoming passionate about
this about both these things
oh my god okay so i i went through hell
the last 10 years have been the hell
that have
given me the opportunity to like
learn and like share my journey
i always like joke with my husband that
i'm like i feel like god literally put
us through every possible thing we could
have gone through so that we are able to
share with like a wide range of people
and like relate to a wide range of
people so
everything that i share is like from
experience
excuse me
um and
it's just like
when i was going through i felt
alone a lot of times like very isolated
especially because i was
a young mom i got married young so i was
like trying to like relate you know with
my marriage issues to like my friends
that are like in college and going to
parties and i'm like so i just felt very
isolated and it wasn't until like i got
older that i'm like looking at all of
these like older couples that i was
looking up to and i'm like oh my god
they all went through this too but no
one talks about it like parents don't
talk about it social media doesn't talk
about like the struggles it's all like
the the beautiful things you know so
when i started to realize that i'm like
there has to be other people that are in
like a dark place in parenting or in
marriage or wanting to do something
different or you know doesn't don't feel
like it'll be accepted in their
support system or don't have a support
system and i just wanted to be
kind of like
a
i i wanted to create a community for
that
so that that is what kind of encouraged
me to start like sharing and i never
expected for it to like get as big as it
did
but um i i feel like i've been able to
like touch a lot of lives and that's
really what's been keeping me going
yeah and partially from what i've seen
of your content based on where you came
from before like especially in your
marriage to where you are today can you
kind of share about that story
oh god
which part
there's there's a lot me my okay
my husband and i got married at 18 and
20.
we were super young we had only been
dating for eight months wow and we were
pregnant by the time we got married wow
so
it was really hard i feel like we kind
of like had to like grow up really fast
and at the same time we also had to like
raise each other because like we were
just kind of like thrown out into the
world with no idea on how to like
what it looks like to be married you
know he came from a home where it was
like
his his parents weren't married but
his stepdad had been in his life since
he was like five and they're still
married to this day so like he he comes
from a home like his grandparents have
been married for like 50 plus years like
he comes from a home of marriage i come
from a home of divorce so
there were a lot of things that like we
didn't really
we weren't on the same page on and like
at the same time no one had really
because we were so young no one had been
like hands on with us about like
guiding us through marriage we just kind
of had to figure it out on our own
and i feel like that in itself caused a
lot of like
conflict and a lot of disconnection
and a lot of um
just like butting heads like
consistently
and
every single thing that we went through
we had to like figure out like what the
lesson was in it
to get us through like the hundreds of
lessons to get us to where we are now
yeah i never thought we would be where
we are now wow ever and you guys started
so young
you
you kind of like were thrust into the
having kids phase right after your
honeymoon phase of your relationship
right not even just like true legitimate
honeymoon after marriage but like the
honeymoon phase of a relationship is
like that beginning phase right and
you're so young so there's like so many
factors that come into play so you had a
lot of stuff against you right
but what brought you through what ch
what was the change for like what was
the pivotal change that brought you
through that to where you guys are today
allergies dear god
it was like it was a runny nose
um
well i'll say for one my husband was in
the military
and that was a lot of pressure so like
when he got out of the military
it it
it changed a lot it's like it gave us
opportunity to actually start growing
because when he was in the military he
was working like 40 plus hours non-stop
24 7. when he was home he was tired he
was grumpy you know so like
coming out of the military is when we
like finally started like going to
counseling and really like started
working on ourselves but i would say
like the real shift came um
after
i got pregnant with my
um my last baby we had like a really big
scare with him
um we found out at
like 27
weeks
that he had um
an enlarged bladder like it was it was
like completely random we went for like
a 3d ultrasound everything was normal we
just wanted to get some fun pictures and
like
the
lady that was in rochester was like
terrified and she was like
when's the last time you've been to the
doctors i'm like
i don't know like you know everything's
fine but um ultimately we ended up
finding out that he had um
something to where
his bladder was enlarged because it
couldn't release and so it was backing
up into his kidney so it got to a point
where they were like whoa
we can do um an abortion like we and i'm
like i'm like 30 weeks pregnant like so
it was a really huge scare and i feel
like
it really was like okay either we're
gonna be in this together like we're
gonna work this out together or we're
gonna go our separate ways because this
was like the trial for us and we really
like buckled through and like pulled
each other through it because we didn't
know if our baby was gonna make it you
know um and that sent us down like a
really deep like spiritual path
and us building on that and finally
being able to like
see each other and and
focus on each other and
build and then he lost his job and so we
had a lot more time together so that
that was kind of like a pivotal point
for us
yeah yeah and then how was it going
through the rest of the pregnancy
together like that that's the point
where you're like finding this growth
and also maybe a little bit scared of
like the unknown right what's going to
happen yeah and how did everything kind
of play out it it it i mean ultimately i
was leaving well because we're better
than we've ever been but
um it was definitely like hard times it
actually makes me kind of sad i know
like
i was saying like i don't i don't know
if we want to have another baby or not
but i'm like i feel like i kind of got
robbed because my last pregnancy was so
scary
yeah i didn't i didn't get to like
thoroughly enjoy it but um
you know it we were really strong in our
faith and like i said that's a period
where we started getting really strong
in our faith so um we were just really
confident that like everything was gonna
work work out we were just really like
staying positive and ultimately
everything did work out um you know my
son still has like issues he still sees
a specialist till this day but like he's
alive he's not yeah you know his life
isn't at risk so
that
that really like strengthened our faith
and it was kind of like okay we got
through that together like we might as
well just finish like getting our stuff
together like yeah and working it out
and um
it just sent us through like i said like
a really deep like spiritual
path to where like everything was
changing our our belief system changed
like everything changed and
it just we were able to kind of create
our own dynamic our own like morals on
like what marriage looks like for us and
like
what
is important to us and what we should
focus on instead of like figuring or
trying to figure out like what it's
supposed to be like what it's supposed
to feel like what what
marriage is supposed to look like that's
when we really started to like create
our own and i think
most of the time or at least for a lot
of people a lot of couples it isn't
until you're at like your really lowest
point where you're like okay this is
like write or die like we're either
gonna have to
figure this out now or it's over and so
by figuring it out that's how you end up
rebuilding your marriage to where it's
even better than it ever was before
right so
is the do you find that like marriage
and like intentional parenting kind of
go hand in hand because i know that
when my husband and i are like on this
really good wavelength where we're both
just like vibing together and we're
really treating each other the way we
should be and we're um deeply bonded
like our children see that and they and
even when we think they're not looking
they are looking and then
they respond in that way like they
respond in a positive way from that
because when they see their parents our
strengths are strengthened and strong
they feel secure they feel confident in
their family life and how's that
experience been for you no yeah
definitely for one i feel like
like everything that we represent or
everything that we believe in is just
it's just intentional lifestyle i feel
like i have to split it up for the
purpose of like social media because i
have a lot of um like community members
that are married but they don't have
kids or you know they have kids but
they're not married so it's like
some can relate to you know some part
some can but
it's just it's just intentional living
it's intentional living it's intentional
eating it's like it's everything goes to
hand in hand so definitely the marriage
part and the parenting part go together
and i feel like they correlate so much
that it's like when i'm giving examples
of like oh this is you know how you're
supposed to treat your child and i have
so many people that are like yeah that's
how you're supposed to treat your
coworkers and like your family members
so it's like the way i try to like
implement like you know communicating
with my husband good communication with
my husband is the same way i try to
implement the communication with my
children like they they cross
um
they cross so much
and definitely like us having
that intentional relationship and being
like intentional with each other not
only does it make my kids feel more like
secure but it's also like
it's modeling for them like how to
communicate and
it like to the point where especially
with my oldest because he's he was the
one that was around for most of like the
drama like he remembers like you guys
used to argue all the time so like he
gets really triggered when we argue like
we're not doing that again i'm like no
we're not even if we're just like joking
around but it's like you know it's loud
he's like no and i'm like we're just
kidding because he will like totally
hold us accountable
um and i love that like i love that he
he's able to see like this is what it's
supposed to look like so like i'm gonna
keep you guys in line and so even if we
get like into a heated discussion he'll
come in and he'll just stand there we're
like yeah we'll bring it down
i've even had my
my three-year-old well she's yeah she's
four now but when she was three at the
time she's had times where she could see
me getting heated and she'd be like mom
everything's gonna be okay she's like
it's okay calm down deep breaths like
she'll say things that i've said to her
and i'm like oh my gosh like that that's
it i know it's the best
i love that i love that my kids do that
too and i'm like it's my favorite part
of parenting is like getting to see them
like model back to me like oh you were
listening
i know all the times when you think that
they're not listening they really are
and it goes the same like you said with
with how their parents are acting it's
totally totally modeling to them how
they should be in life and how they
should treat others right yeah so can
you tell us some of your marriage
secrets what are some of those secrets
i've seen you like do some real like
marriage secrets part one and two like
what what can people
gain those special secrets from to like
help rebuild their marriage and just
strengthen their bond
so i would say number one
biggest like transition for us
um
and i'm like i don't know if they're
like secrets per se
but number one is like communication
like i don't think people really realize
how important communication is because i
feel like most people aren't raised to
like communicate effectively like that's
not something you learn in like school
like you know like it's just not and
it's not something your parents really
teach you
so i feel like
so many arguments that me and my husband
had could have been
avoided
by
just having like proper communication
and like
having like that like empathy factor and
like listening and not just like i'm
waiting for you to finish talking so i
can talk you know there's a lot of like
ego that goes into communication and if
you're not communicating like
intentionally and like
bringing that ego down and actually like
connecting with your partner even when
they're like saying things that you
don't want to hear or you're frustrated
with them um
like it can go really south if you're
not if you're not being intentional
about that so i feel like that was one
of the biggest
changes that we made that like
significantly changed our relationships
like
changing the way we communicate with
each other and even like the parts that
weren't even like
necessarily improper but it just
it wasn't
our communication style like my husband
like i said he's very like military and
he's very like tough love and you know
and i'm like i'm he's the oldest in his
family i'm the baby
so i'm like don't talk to me like that
like
talk to me gently
so it was like
so much like going back and forth and
like him trying to understand like i
don't understand why what i'm saying to
you is wrong and i'm like it's not wrong
it's just how you're saying it yeah like
oh my gosh the amount of arguments my
husband i had have had because of that
simple simple thing it's not even what
you're saying it's just the way you're
saying right to me
and they're just like i don't even know
what you're talking about like get over
it like that it is like the biggest
biggest part um so that's definitely
like one of the hugest things and we
actually just finished filming um like a
whole like communication course
because
it's just it's not something that
people talk to you about but it's like
one of the most effective things for
like changing
the dynamic of your relationship so in
every relationship like every any
relationship that's the heart the
harmony the synchronicity like that's
not a word synchronicity that's not a
word my sister's gonna make fun of me
synchronistic it doesn't matter we're on
the same page we're on the same page you
know what i'm talking about like all of
it together is everything goes so much
smoother when you like have
really good communication skills and how
to talk to other people yeah and it's
like it all
it all comes down to like self and
that's that's also something that like a
lot of people don't really
realize like we go into the world like
blaming other people and trying to
figure out what other people are doing
that's causing the problem and it's like
sometimes
it's us it's like what's that that
communicate like i have a i i'm i do a
lot better now i say i'm at like 89 but
i've always had a really bad issue with
like body language and that just pushes
my husband's buttons because like he can
be talking to me and i'm like rolling my
eyes and crossing my arms and he's like
you're not never mind like i don't want
to talk to you when i'm like i'm
listening to you i'm quiet so it's just
like those little things that it's like
you can totally play the victim and be
like i was just sitting there and
listening and then he just stormed off
and you don't take accountability for
like what you're doing to contribute and
that was like that was also like a big
thing that we had to like look into
ourselves you know instead of just
blaming each other for everything
we're brought to you today by a favorite
apothecary shop of mine called anema
mundi herbals they specialize in high
potency elixirs medicinal mushrooms and
collagen boosters and support true fair
trade practices beyond organic farming
education and small farmers to create
remedies that benefit people from all
walks of life i love the immunity
boosters in their shop including black
elderberry syrup mushroom mocha milk and
spirulina which is an organic protein
rich mineralizer that tastes delicious
in banana mango smoothies the robust
protein found in spirulina containing
all nine of the essential amino acids is
extremely bioavailable with up to 85
digestibility and it's rich in b
vitamins which are essential to the
health of the central nervous system and
the brain to boost your mood and
cognitive power
i'm also obsessed with their happiness
powder which is an energizing and mood
boosting herbal coffee that is caffeine
free and adaptogenic and is energized
with some of the top herbs researched to
increase a sense of peace and happiness
such as ashwagandha i like it served
warm with plant milk and maple syrup but
my favorite items in their shop tend to
my feminine and pregnant body their
goddess magic healing and moisturizing
bundle includes a collagen booster face
oil wound tea blue lotus flowers and a
rose body oil which is just a fine anima
mundi uses eco-friendly packaging in
recyclable glass or biodegradable bags i
got an awesome discount code for you
guys so use my code ellen15 for 15 off
anything at
nimamoondiherbl.com that's
a-n-i-m-a-m-u-n-d-i-h-e
yeah i definitely think that the
majority of the time it's so easy for us
when we go into a disagreement with
anyone or an argument
especially with your partner um but
anybody right you you go into it like
what they did wrong right instead of
being like what did what role did i play
right what what did i do that i could
learn from and that i can do differently
next time and instead of like blaming
everybody else for your problems like
taking accountability for yourself and
be like well i all i can change is
myself yes all i can change is what i
can do to help the situation and if you
both are doing that right
fireworks it's gonna be a major
difference instead of pointing and
blaming because when you go into an
argument and you're like well no you did
this and this and this i don't like the
way you did this and if you're bolting
on each other like that the way the
likelihood it's going to be resolved
easily is a lot smaller yes then
then the way that you can talk in a
healthy way so what would be an example
of like a healthy way that you can
communicate
when you're having a disagreement with
your partner you could see the argument
getting heated like what's an example of
how to talk differently one way you're
maybe tempted to talk instead of like
how to shift even the language of what
you would say oh gosh
i don't know if it's even i feel like
one one way that we really shift the
language specifically is like
that accountability language so like
taking accountability for like your
feelings and not like
um forcing your feelings onto that other
person's like actions
so like
i know that like one of the things that
used to irritate my husband so bad like
it will always end up bad when i was
like you have an attitude or like you're
being this or you're acting this way
instead of me being like well i feel
like you feel this way like do you feel
that way you know so then he can tell me
for himself like no i don't or yes i do
no i don't have attitude yes i do i'm
upset about something you know like it
and it was the same thing for me like
there's just something about someone
telling you how you feel
that's like super flustering so i feel
like one of the ways that we just
really respected each other and rest
with the respect to each other's um
feelings and individualities was like
taking a moment to like
redirect that
and
take accountability for the fact that we
may just be perceiving it that way
they may not feel that way or if they do
feel that way giving them like
a stage and a safe space to like
share instead of like throwing it at
them and be like oh you have an attitude
you know
that that was yeah that was a really
really big one for us yeah i definitely
have found that helpful too like saying
more like i'm feeling this way i'm
feeling
unheard or i'm feeling um like maybe you
don't care about my feelings or i'm
feeling instead of saying you don't care
about my feelings
you're this and that it's just saying
like this is how i'm feeling from the
situation and then they're more likely
to be able to receive that right a lot
better and then another one
which i kind of use i mean like i said
it's all universal but like even with my
kids and with my husband is like giving
that moment of like acknowledgement
before
giving a response
because i feel like like especially when
you get into like an argument or like
heated discussion so like back and forth
back and forth my turn to talk my turn
to talk my turn you know so like giving
that person like honor first of like hey
i i hear you i i completely understand
what you're saying
i feel this way like just that small
like acknowledgement of like their their
feelings
letting them know that like
i heard you i wasn't just
thinking in my head about how i'm gonna
respond to you and cuss you out right
now it was like i actually listened to
you that changes
how we communicate a lot yes oh my gosh
anytime my husband and i get into even
if it's like a little disagreement
sometimes your ego can be tempted to
just be like dismiss it or be like oh
that's so like just get over it or you
know that's an easy thing to say instead
of saying like oh i i didn't realize
that that bothered you like i'm sorry
and then it's like over like some
something like that something so simple
a lot of times and then you can maybe
say how you're feeling like you can say
how you're feeling afterwards it depends
on the situation right but sometimes
like for my husband and i it could be
something really little that i just feel
like okay you know this bothered me like
and it's easy to just want to like
dismiss it but then that actually makes
you it's like a like love coin taking
out of your bank like you're like oh i
feel unheard like right the way i feel
didn't matter to him right um but
instead responding in a way that's like
oh like i didn't realize that would
bother you like i'm sorry even just
something so little like that goes the
longest way it does and it's like even
i try to do even if i'm like oh my god
what he's saying right now is total bs
but it's like it's it's
all about like i said that ego and like
understanding that
we are not two individual people we are
one team working together and like when
that ego hits i feel like sometimes it
it makes you feel like it's me against
him it's him you know against me it's me
against the world so like you naturally
go into that like defense mode to where
it's like i have to protect me so i feel
like when you're more conscious about
that and realizing that like we're a
team this person loves me and i love
them as well like it's not you know um
it it makes it
it just makes the goal more clear of
like okay he's feeling unheard right now
i don't agree with what he's saying but
i'm going to make sure that he feels
heard because
that's going to be important to him and
it's going to be important in
closing this discussion now in a
peaceful way instead of escalating it
it's kind of like that like taking one
for the team like
picking your battles
yeah i've seen you say before how when
you shifted your mindset from like me
against him him against me to us against
the problem
that is a really i feel like
revolutionary way to to consider the
issue at hand be like okay now it's us
and against the problem we're trying to
figure out this problem together right
and that i feel like that shifts a lot
in your mindset yeah and something else
that i see you share a lot is about is
intimacy so how can couples make time
for intimacy when your life is so busy
especially with raising young kids right
yeah that was actually i was like that's
gonna be like my number two like
marriage secret oh my god oh yeah i know
we only really got into one very secret
well you had two so yeah we got two
secrets uh no intimacy is so important
and i feel like that was number two that
might have been number like that that
and communication might have gone hand
in hand of like destroying my marriage
like if we did not go through that
get through that i don't know if me and
my husband would be together till this
day um and
it's just this simple it's not even
about sex
it's just it's intimacy
it's
so important and it's another one of
those things that it's like it's not
taught and especially for men but even
for women i feel like us as women we
kind of crave intimacy naturally
um but
like
it's not something we're taught about
you know and it's not something men are
taught about so like when
people come together
it's like okay do we have a little bit
of time let's have sex and it's like
it doesn't have to be sex and we kind of
came to that realization because like
after i had my first born
my
my sex drive was like out the window
like it was gone
and like it was like we went through a
phase where i was like do you like me
anymore and i'm like yeah no you're
great it was just like
there was
nothing everything in your body is going
towards like taking care of your baby
and it's very natural especially like
with breast being like the hormones in
your body um is all focused on like not
making more children it's on raising
this baby that you have right in front
of you yeah it's a huge shift for for
moms and it's like
i feel like it's something that like we
get like ashamed about so like we don't
talk about it so that was like one of
those things where i was like
like
going through such a dark place because
i'm like oh my god i'm broken
what's wrong with me um and it took
years literally years and it like it got
to a point where it was like it was
causing a disconnection between us
because we didn't know how else to be
intimate it was like we came out we came
into
marriage young and like frisky and that
was our thing you know so it was like
okay it's like
now what now you know and it's like now
it's not just like oh we can just like
cuddle up or you know like whatever any
time because now we have a child now we
have two children now we have three
children so
when we started like really deep
focusing on intimacy
it took a huge shift in our relationship
that was like the biggest like the last
and biggest shift that we took that sent
us like in the right direction
and when we started that we actually
started we just came to the conclusion
cause i was just like dude like i'm just
not interested in sex like i'm just not
and so
we did like a no sex fast
for 30 days and like we were just we
were just like okay we're not doing it
you know when we are doing it we're not
enjoying it because
you know i don't want to do it and he
wants to do it he can't enjoy it if i
don't want to do it so it's just like
let's just be intentional about it
and during that time like we really just
focused on like connecting like in a
spiritual way and like eye-gazing and
meditating and like just focusing on
each other because prior to that it was
like our intimate time or time when we
weren't like having sex was like
watching a movie or you know something
whereas like we weren't actually
focusing on each other right so like we
did during that time it was like no
screens like it was like super strict
and
that was like the best 30 days of our
life and like after that was over it was
like
fireworks yeah it all came
and so it was like a realization like oh
my god like i'm like of course part of
it was like hormonal but also i feel
like i was able to overcome that because
i was like
i was able to reconnect with my husband
like deeply reconnect with him and
moving forward from that like 30-day
fast we kind of started to realize that
like it didn't it didn't take like long
date nights and walks on the beach like
it was just like those pockets of time
that we reserved for each other that
were like only focused on us
and so that's um what i tell like a lot
of people because a lot of people like
well what do i do and i don't have time
to spend time with my husband and i'm
like well when you are when you and your
husband are home what do you do oh we
watch tv together okay turn the tv off
start that right to turn the tv off like
if the kids are like asleep take like 15
minutes you know before
you guys go to bed like i know you're
tired take that 15 minutes like
just do something intimate
it doesn't take a lot i feel like the
thought that like it takes hours of time
to get a connection it just
automatically makes you feel like
defeated and it's like oh i don't you
know i don't have time for that so that
that was our that's been our thing that
like gets us through like those pockets
of time and like we dedicate those times
to each other even if it's just like if
we're separate and we're texting or you
know like whatever we dedicate those
times and then we also have like
dedicated like
nights where either we'll do like a date
night or we'll do like a sex night like
we're like this is happening on this
night no matter what you know and it's
like we make sure we reserve the time so
that like it doesn't feel rushed and we
can take time to connect and you know
and it's like when you really are like
deeply focusing on
those moments
it will get you over to the next moment
it's enough to get you to the next
moment and keep you connected
yeah i totally agree with that totally
resonate with it i don't know if you've
ever heard of kim and nami but she's
this like incredible sex guru that i had
on my podcast and the episode is called
transform your sex life for those
listening or watching and i definitely
recommend you check it out it was like
it was like a very mind-blowing her
philosophy and the stuff that she shares
is totally life-changing and
transforming at least for my husband and
i like totally transformed our sex life
and our intimacy um and one of the
things she talks about
is keeping the simmer throughout the day
and it's like as you know it isn't
always the case like the men women right
but for a lot of women or most women
it's one of these things where you can't
just be like oh you know i've been busy
all day like my hair's disheveled i'm
doing the dishes i got spit up on my
whatever of my clothes and changing
diapers all day and now it's like oh we
got 20 minutes
babe's like quick let's have sex and
you're not like yeah i'm so excited to
have sex right now like this is all i
want to focus my energy on right because
you have so many other things going on
in your head and if you haven't been
keeping that simmer all throughout the
day
where you even if it's like not like you
don't not with your partner during the
day but like throughout the week right
little things like a text and things
that when you do so each see each other
that you are connecting and being
intimate not with the idea that you're
about to have sex but just because you
love each other and it's that intimacy
that you have for each other that love
and um
like it's basically a sex drive that you
have for each other too
that keeps that simmer going all
throughout the day and week and then
when it is time to have sex you are so
ready to go
because if you don't have any of that
um it's a lot harder especially when you
have young kids you know because things
are changing like things do change with
you especially when you just have a baby
but also just when you have so much
going on in your head and it's like the
last thing on your mind because i can't
even tell you how different it is if you
get alone time with your partner for
like a two day period you're like wow
i'm like a completely different person
i'm totally into wanting to have sex all
like all day
you know because i have nothing else on
my mind right but because of real life
and raising kids
that intimacy throughout the day and
keeping that simmer is so important and
so we found that like oh even something
as little as just brushing up against
each other like when you're clean that's
just coming up behind your partner and
loving on each other for like 5 10 20 30
seconds right
that stuff throughout the day and a text
and looking at each other the things you
say to each other that something like
sexy like
then that prepares you for that time
when you do have that time to have sex
yes yeah no yeah that's that is
key yeah and i feel like it's super
important like
i feel like it's so easy for like women
to adapt to that but i feel like it's a
it's sometimes a hard concept for like
men oh yeah especially because it's like
we're just we're different like most men
it's like they're they can any time any
you know any
circumstance you know and like we do
like especially after having kids and
the hormonal changes everything like we
have to be
warmed up yeah you know to it so it's
like i feel like that's so important for
them to understand because
that was like one of the things like
back in the day it was like my husband
would come home from work i'll be with
the kids all day and it's like all right
we have 10 minutes let's do it like i
haven't even seen you all day bro
like there's no no nothing here so yeah
no that's
super important and then like the other
thing i feel like
changed for me
personally like doing my own self work
was like my own self love and like self
care and that's like
another thing i feel like like a lot of
us like rely on our partner to make us
feel like good
but and it's like if we don't
once that's lost if that disconnection
gets lost then it's like
what do we do you know
and so like when i actually started like
just taking like a little moment even
like days where i'm like okay i'm gonna
do my makeup today like i'm gonna get
out of my pajamas today
i'm gonna do something that makes me
feel like myself because like how do you
connect with that younger version of
yourself pre-children and pre-like
stress and you know that was like
ready you know and willing to do that
all the time if you're not you're not
even connected with that person
and um one of the things for me like i
used to love to dance that was like my
thing i was never very good at it but i
love to do it and so um
after i had my third i
joined a
pole dancing studio oh cool and i
started pole dancing like for fitness
but like
i was like oh my gosh this makes me feel
so sexy like this makes me feel good and
i noticed like that feeling good i was
more like it it helped with my sex drive
it made me feel more willing you know
because i'm like i feel sexy like i
don't want to
you know i don't want to engage with you
when i feel like trash and i feel like i
look like a wildebeest like i just don't
absolutely yeah
love that okay so i have another
question that about is to ask you is
i've seen you share about how porn was
destroying your marriage can you share a
little bit about that
oh man yeah that's one um it's a great
segue yeah no it is about intimacy it is
no it is for sure and it all it
definitely relates um it's funny because
it's like i've never actually talked
about it on camera okay but no but i
mean like let's get into it let's go
um
so yeah
i feel like
so many of us are introduced to sex the
wrong way
and
a lot of that is just
early exposure
to porn or you know whatever like
whatever it might have been like a movie
with like a sex scene or i feel like
like 90 babies 90s babies and before
like there was not as much like
censorship
because i'm like i my kids watch like pg
movies and like i remember
like my parents watching rated r movies
and when the sex scenes came they're
just like close your eyes it's just like
i can still see between your fingers
so i feel like that early exposure
it just creates a really unhealthy
relationship with sex really unhealthy
and really unrealistic because it's like
that that's basically that's where we
learn about sex
we're not paying attention to what
they're teaching in school we're using
the visual aids that we have at home so
with my husband like specifically that
was something like he was exposed to
very early
in life
and like it really really damaged like
how he viewed
sex
we're also brought to you today by buffy
you guys know how much i love these
incredibly soft sheets in bedding and
for a limited time you can get 20 off
orders over 80 dollars just use my code
ellen at checkout you will be blown away
how soft and cozy their cloud comforter
is and the sheets are divine but aside
from that what makes a buffy purchase
even better is that they use only
renewable and recycled materials which
makes them as soft on the planet as they
are on your bed the cloud comforter is
covered in ultra breathable eucalyptus
fabric which uses 10 times less water
than cotton to grow and its fiber is
produced using recyclable earth-friendly
solvents eucalyptus also naturally
soothes the skin for an incredible
relaxing night's sleep but i'm not done
with reasons why i am such a huge fan of
buffy the best part for me is that the
average down comforter harms 12 geese
but buffy's comforter is cruelty free
using 100 recycled water bottles that
are transformed and given a second life
as super fluffy fiber it feels even
softer than down while keeping
approximately 50 bottles out of
landfills and oceans this comforter has
over 18 000 five-star reviews and keeps
you at the perfect temperature so you
feel cozy without overheating it's
hypoallergenic and machine washable
thanks to an innovative stitching powder
that keeps its fluffy fill in place so
don't forget to use my code ellen at
checkout you can try a comforter in your
own bed for free if you don't love it
return it at no cost
and
i feel like i i kind of had that same
exposure
but
maybe
with me being like
a female and like everything we just
talked about like going into like
motherhood and like all that it just it
played out differently for me because it
was like by the end of it like i didn't
i i just wasn't interested anymore but
it was like that was kind of like his
thing that it like kept him going
because we were going such long periods
without having sex you know and
i just like with everything that we went
through and like
now to a point where we've
we've had so many conversations like so
many like deep conversations of like
tears and just like you know like just
really digging into like our past and
what we went through
we really came to that realization like
he was like it was it was ruining me you
know it was ruining like the
my perception of like what sex was
supposed to be like and it and it was
ruining me because i'm like okay you're
watching that i'm not living up to that
right now like i'm not i'm not even
there i don't look like that i don't
feel like that you know so it was just
causing such a huge disconnection
between us um and it's just it's so
perceived by like society is like normal
yeah it is and so like for him it was
like what like it's just porn you know
but i was like it it doesn't feel good
like it doesn't feel right you know but
it's like how do you explain that to
someone when it's like
it's normal it's like hey i'm just
eating a cheeseburger what's wrong with
cheeseburgers you know and it's like i
don't know but i just don't like how
it's
working out right now so it that was a
really huge disconnect and it was kind
of like okay well we're not having sex
so
what else are we you know what what else
so it was kind of like all right you
know just you know whatever but
it just
all it did was
eat at the disconnection
and
when i like share that with people i get
so much like oh well we use it to like
fuel our fire and well
you know it's it's it works out for us
it's fine for us but it's like at the
root of it
and that's my my opinion i can only
share my my opinion my experience
i feel like we used that as an excuse
several times before too like we tried
to use like
porn as like a pregame i'm like okay you
like it maybe it'll help you know but it
was just like
now having the connection that i that i
have with my husband like
there's no comparison
you know it's like like it's a
it's almost like oh well
i
take drugs because they help me you know
focus on this or make me feel better
about this and it's like
okay but those drugs are bad
at the root of it it's it's kind of like
a crutch because like you need to be
able to function without them you know
yeah you're giving away your power
exactly so it was just eating at the
disconnection and it was like a crutch
that we were using to kind of like
i don't know but
when we got rid of it like we was like
okay we're not doing this anymore and
it's funny because like i had i had been
like telling my i mean like we grew up
like christian so that was like one
thing um even though that's not like our
belief system anymore but it was just
like i was telling my husband like i
just
i don't like it like it just doesn't
make me feel good and he was just kind
of like brushing it off but then like
after all he's like
i think i'm gonna stop watching porn and
i was like why he's like i think i'm
getting like bad karma
he's like i just noticed like every time
i go and sneak and watch porn we end up
in like a really huge argument like even
though you don't know about it he's like
i just feel like god is like like
showing me like what
this is actually doing to my marriage
and so
he was just like i think like i don't
want to watch it anymore like i want you
know something different like i want to
connect with you like i want us to get
through this so
we decided like okay we're gonna do away
with porn we're not doing it anymore
we're not giving into that like culture
and
like i said following that that's when
like we really got deep into that like
spiritual path and like focusing on each
other and that intimacy and sex on like
a spiritual level and it's like it's
next level like it's not
it's not anything that any of that can
offer but i feel like
you can't even attain that when you're
indulging in this
yeah i agree i do think it's bringing
other people into your bedroom into your
love life and it's not
it's creating less intimacy unrealistic
expectations there's a lot of problems
with young
young kids like you said having access
to it so early and like you said about
like pre-90s i actually think it's worse
now because so many kids are getting
smart phones at such a young age i want
to do a whole episode on this people
have listened to a lot of my episodes
they know how i feel about like young
kids with smartphones um and the
potential problems that come with it um
which is having unlimited access to the
internet unsupervised i mean we already
had that even before smartphones with
computers right and maybe naively
parents you know back then might have
thought oh like not big deal like if i'm
not supervising or making sure the
content that is being viewed is
appropriate for their age and all that
but now it's even worse because they
have complete access to the internet at
all times unlimited information and
unlimited types of imagery and so it can
create
addiction
all types of things and unrealistic
expectations of what sex is supposed to
be like what women are supposed to be um
and there's also like abuse even within
that industry so i definitely think
there's a lot of problems with it um and
i agree i think that you can
i mean there's so many stories like
yours where once they get rid of that
they're able to deepen their intimacy
and strengthen their bond in their
relationship and that's actually
something kim nami also talks about
which i think is pretty cool you gotta
check her out yeah no i'm for sure
so what now coming to the end of this
like all these things that you guys went
through what is it that helped like what
was the final point that made you decide
like we're gonna heal our marriage i
know you said it was like that point
when you found out about your son like
what what tools helped you do that did
you just figure it out on your own or
did you like read books like what is it
that made you guys just like come to
where you are today to figure out how to
do it are you guys just like really good
at winging it and figuring it out we've
definitely done a lot of winging it i'm
not gonna lie um
so i feel like
we we
we had a lot of like
checkpoints i like to say like it was
like literally like like god would put
us through like a test and it'll be like
all right checkpoint level up
okay checkpoint level up so it's like
there's like a lot of different like
points that i can like go back and be
like okay yeah that was where we got
here that was where we got here but like
it was like we finally got to this point
where it was like everything
came to like a head
and like
through that like i mean like if you
follow me like you know
like we've gone through everything from
like domestic abuse to like
infidelity like there's just been so
many dark places in our marriage
and that's i like why i'm so proud of us
and that's why i like root for like if
you want to stay in your marriage and
you and your partner actually like want
to make it work like
you can get through it you know because
and not only just make it work but like
thrive and heal and like restore yes oh
my gosh like that's like such a
testimony yes yes literally um it's it's
funny you said that cause i was
literally i had a facebook memory pop-up
and it was from like eight years ago
no maybe it was like six years ago and
it was like
i said something like i was like i know
that god is using my marriage right now
so that i can create a bigger testimony
later or something like that and i was
like wow
because it was just like it was really
hard like and especially being young
like i told myself i'm like i'm shocked
that we're still together um because we
went through a lot and it wasn't out of
like ill intentions it was just out of
us being young and misguided you know
and so like everything kind of like came
to a to a head where it was like over
time we were kind of like slowly opening
back up to each other and slowly healing
and slowly like sharing but then like we
finally got to like a like point where
we were like we were just like okay like
tell all like i'm gonna tell you like
everything i've ever done
felt like in this marriage like ever you
know like my my real viewpoint like how
i felt about you doing that or like you
like whatever like we we just had like a
session where we just like spilled
everything and like we just like cried
and like for days like it was literally
like over a course of like three days it
was like a huge like healing like
ceremony
and after that it was just like
it was like
you know after you cry like how you just
like like you just feel so much better
it was literally like that it was like a
breath of like fresh air
and
from that point moving forward like
we just
continued to build on that and
it was like during that journey we had
received like a lot of tools like i said
like we went to counseling like we were
reading books we were doing a lot of
things but because we were still kind of
like
keeping walls up to each other and we
weren't still being like 100 honest with
each other like it just it we weren't
able to receive it the same way so it
was like after that happened we were
really able to like
start implementing those things
implementing the things that we had
learned in counseling implementing the
things that like we had learned about
and like we were just like doing a lot
of like self-study like my husband was
like
my husband like come i'm so proud of him
coming from like where he came from like
i said like that early exposure and like
porn addiction and like all of that and
like now like he like studies like
ancient like chinese methods of like
like
like i don't even know i don't even know
like he studies so much stuff that has
to do with like semen retention and like
sex secrets and like how to like like
all these things that are like have to
do with
like
maintaining his own like control and not
you know like
like over-indulging or like you know
just
like for the sake of for one like him
growing as a person and two like for him
being like the man that i need you know
for the times when i don't you know if
i'm going through it i don't want to you
know have sex like he doesn't feel like
it's such a big difference from back in
the day where it's like okay what am i
supposed to do to now he's like it's
okay like take your time like he'll tell
me all the time because i still have
like little moments where i'll get like
emotional like if we
get like you know he wants to do it and
i'm just like i'm not up to it and i'll
still get like really emotional because
i'm like i don't want to disappoint you
and he's like it's okay like he's like
we can go a week a month two months he's
like when it happens like it's gonna be
worth the wait like it's okay like he's
a completely different person and it's
it's been a lot of winging it a lot like
studying on our own a lot a lot because
like i said
no one ever taught us these things and
that's why we share the little things
like oh like
marriage secrets or you know it's not
that it's like necessarily a secret it's
just that
no one ever shared it with us
so it's like all the things that we've
kind of learned on our journey along the
way just like with our own just
journeying out on our own we kind of
wanted to like start
sharing that with other people that no
one probably ever told them either yeah
that's beautiful
okay so i want to shift a little bit
about talking about your book you have a
book called revised not repeated a brown
mom's guide to breaking general
generational curse curses and parenting
can you tell me about that book yes
that's a mouthful i know
i just failed at that i don't think it's
that much
so i actually started writing this book
back in
i think it was like 2019 like early
2019. i started writing it like i was
just
randomly i don't even know what i was
doing one day and like the title just
pops into my head like god just gave me
the title and i was like
okay
and that was like before i had like my
platform before i was doing any of this
um and i was just kind of like like
just
going
through my own parenting journey and
like still learning you know on my own
but like i was like really really
starting like to implement like
the intentional parenting and the gentle
parenting and like changing the dynamic
of like how i parented because it was so
different from like how i was parented
or what i
experienced not even just from like my
parents or like just like
our culture like in general like um and
especially like brown parents it was
like we had like this
this
oh gosh like culture that embraces
like
certain
parenting styles and certain like habits
that i just felt like were toxic and it
was like growing up i was like why is
this normal like and it's like everybody
would just kind of like laugh about it
and i'm like this isn't funny but it was
like at the same time like i don't want
to be like the outcast you know of the
group
um and
so i remember like i wrote down the
title and i started writing on it and
then i
stopped and i never came back to it
and so it was um
after like
back in 2021
but it was like
maybe like
august july something like that and my
husband had just published his book
and so or he actually hadn't published
that he he was still writing it but he
was like at the end of it and like i
just kept getting this voice in my head
like god was telling me like
go back to your book and i'm like what
book
it's like go back to your book it was
like every day i had completely
forgotten about it but i've always loved
writing and like watching him write i
was like just getting really inspired i
was like i really want to write but like
i don't know if i have the time like i
have all this going on i have three kids
and you know and so like
that message just kept coming back to me
i'm like what are you talking about and
so then i was like oh my god okay so i'm
like going back in my computer
and i couldn't remember the title
because obviously this was like years
before that i written it down so i'm
like searching through everything and
i'm like
did i have like am i tripping did i have
a bird like
and so like it took literally like i was
searching for like three days i would
give up and i'll come back out and give
up come back at it and then one day i
found and it was like in my google docs
like my old google docs and it popped up
and i was like
oh my god and so it literally i think i
had only written like the first like
chapter and a half or something like
that um
and from that point i think it was like
august
my book was published in november i was
writing like non-stop like i just got so
inspired and
it was like it dawned on me that it was
perfect that i put it down at that time
because i'm like i've learned so much
more since then that i would not have
been able to offer
as much then as i can now
um but i just really wanted something
for one i wanted something
that i felt like me as a brown mom and
like other brown moms can relate to and
that's why i gave it that title and gave
it like the the representation of like a
brown mom on the cover and a brown child
because
when i started doing like self-study and
looking into like parenting books you
don't see a lot of parenting books that
are written by
brown women or men or you know anything
it's it's
just not
common and it kind of frustrated me that
it's like that's
a constant like stereotype of like oh
you're parenting like a white mom that's
a white person thing and i'm like no
it's not like so i really i hate that i
hate it so much and i really wanted that
representation of like
this this
is not just a white mom thing it's this
is
it's a thing you know like and it's a
good thing and it's and it's never good
to like cast entire groups as like a
monolith like as if they all have one
way of thinking one way of exactly
parenting one way of doing this in life
like no sorry no exactly it's just it's
not true and i felt like that was one of
the reasons like with me growing up and
feeling like
like i think i posted about when i
posted my first like gentle parenting
video
and i was like i had it in my drafts for
like three months because i was so
scared to share it because prior to that
it's like i had my platform but i was
just sharing general like motherhood
like like
just motherhood in general you know not
specifically on like how i parented my
children because i was so scared that
people were gonna judge me and i was
just like social media is just already
it can already be a very toxic place as
is and i just try to stay like as
positive as possible i have enough
things to be stressed about so i was
just like i don't want to share this
like i don't want people like telling me
that i'm raising my kids wrong or you
know other things so
um
it was like
three months later that i finally shared
it and like it went viral
and i seen like how many people were
like oh my god like you parent like me
oh my god you parent like me and i've
always been told this is wrong and my
family's always judged me and i have no
family support and so like i just really
wanted something that number one like
the that my community specifically could
resonate with and look at and like like
show a family member like no this is not
just for white people like look at this
but like just
can relate to um and have something that
like
they feel like it's
targeted to them and and not like
they're an outcast and feel like they do
have like a support system you know even
if they might not have a support system
but beyond that i just wanted something
in general
for people that are like unfamiliar with
this parenting style that it's it's new
to them it's it or if they are just like
wanting to get started on it and they
just need something very basic for me it
was like a lot of the books sometimes
are like overwhelming i'm like okay
1227 pages like and it's a lot to take
in and then it's like okay where do i
start you know so i just wanted like a
really easy like
here here's some really easy good like
practical things this is where you start
and then also like i wanted something
that's like short like you can see it
it's super short and like as a mom i'm
like i do a lot of like audio books
because i don't always have time to read
but then it's like sometimes i miss like
being able to like highlight things like
go back
and
i feel like when i when i read like my
first like parenting book all the way
through i just felt like so accomplished
and i'm like i want other moms to feel
this way that might not have the time to
dedicate to to read a whole thousand
page book or 800 page book you know they
might only have you know a few moments
out of every day to read a book and i've
had so many people reach out to me and
they're like oh my god i read your book
in like two days and it helps so much
and i just feel so accomplished and i
just think that's like a really great
feeling and it's a really great like
motivator to like continue
to learn and grow so that was like my
that was like my motivation
those are my goals in
in publishing my book that's awesome and
for those listening or watching who
don't have your same background can they
also benefit from the book or is it
specifically for brown moms no no yeah
anybody anybody i've had dads by myself
and tell me like oh my god this helped
me you know feel like have a better
connection with my child so yeah yeah no
i i feel like any parent can relate
to the book and any parent can learn
from the book yep perfect so why is it
so important then for people who are
like new to this idea of breaking toxic
patterns from gender past generations um
why is it so pivotal and important for
for that in parenting can you explain it
like what does what does it do when you
break that
oh god it i feel like
it just
starts
i mean
it
it starts a whole new generation
like and
the more that i mean as like from a
community perspective it's like the more
that we phase out some of those toxic
patterns i just feel like
collectively
we're
raising a completely different
generation
of people and i feel like
i can't wait until all of our kids get
older i have so many people they're like
oh these kids are gonna grow up and be
so entitled and they're gonna be this
and that and the next and i'm like
just wait just wait like i i'm so happy
that this wave is happening like i've
never been so happy for like a trend
um i'm so happy that this parenting
style became like trendy and it's it's
reaching so many different people so
many so many different people
um because i feel like
when all of these kids grow up it's
gonna be such an amazing generation of
people just looking at my children and
it's like when people make like snarky
comments online i just like laugh at it
like
someone had made a comment like
the other day kind of referencing that
like
because
my child
did something behind my back and then i
um my three-year-old and then i
disciplined him for it by like making
him clean it up but then i let him help
me anyway i don't know if you seen that
i saw it yeah i loved it and they were
like oh
something to the effect of like
well you know just imagine what this
could do for like
you know men who
you know are rapists and they don't
learn what no means and i'm like
are you saying that
no like
like it's like the comments are so
far-fetched so i just i really can't
wait to see like what this next
generation is going to look like and i
feel like the more parents that get on
board and the more parents that like
understand
like
the bigger picture of this we're just
going to raise such an amazing community
of
little people yeah i do i agree it's
like taking it's creating big waves for
sure and i was kind of raised i think
looking back now i didn't realize then
but i was kind of raised in a positive
respectful gentle parenting way before
it was even a thing before there was
like a word for it right and then like i
don't even think my parents like my you
know my mom's like i don't i don't know
any kind of wording like that it was
just it was just what she did and and i
didn't realize that it wasn't as common
right as it is becoming now today right
yeah so i mean children's like the
innocence within them and like
we're us as parents doing what we can to
protect our children and to you know
hold them and and raise them in a way
where they feel secure and loved and
like i love everything you're sharing
about that and so and i mean like it's
funny because like my mom always like
you better not be talking bad about me
but it's like i i actually i have a
great relationship with my mom i talk to
my mom
probably like five times a day and i
feel also like very blessed i feel like
like a lot of people ask me like oh so
like does this mean that you had a
terrible upbringing i'm like no yeah
like i wasn't abused you know i i feel
like there's different levels to like
parenting and like intentional parenting
and that's why i'm like i don't blame
the last generation i don't i don't
go around like shaming like oh you know
shame on you know because everybody had
their different motives and i know with
like my mom specifically and we've like
talked about this even though there are
like certain aspects of how she parented
me where like i would not pass those
things on to like how i'm parenting my
children we definitely have our
differences yeah and i definitely have
my own like little personal traumas just
from
little things about my childhood not
even just my mom with my dad um but
she wasn't a bad parent and i've had to
like explain the time like you're not
like i don't think you're a bad parent
she had her things that she was trying
to escape from like she came from things
in her family where she was like i'm not
ever gonna let that happen to my child
and it was like those were the things
that she focused on is like i made sure
this didn't happen to you and that you
know didn't have to because these were
the things that caused me trauma and
that was her way of intentionally yeah
impair you know parenting me and making
sure i'd have to look at those things
and i'm blessed to not have had to go
through those things um
and i think that
if we can accept that each generation we
are supposed to grow
and we are supposed to adapt um
to change you know and and the new
information knowledge available to us
like in that generation we in that
generation they didn't even have a lot
of the same knowledge and understanding
of like how children's brains work and
like development and all those things so
it's like how can you
parent in this way how can you know not
to like scream at your child or you know
some of these things that were probably
normalized back then
when you didn't even have this
information available to you yeah where
i do want people to take accountability
is like now that this information is
available now we have to level up of
course our children are probably going
to have things where they're like yeah
my parents did that and that was crazy
oh yeah now we have this information so
we're not doing that anymore and it's
like i expect that with every generation
but at the very least that is what we
should be doing every generation should
be
taking accountability and and
acknowledging the new information that
is available
and educating themselves and leveling up
to the next level yeah i think it's so
important to preface that like
everyone's doing their best for the most
part and we're all just navigating life
based on our own lens and our experience
and so this isn't about like blaming
your past your parents and the way that
you grew up because even you know even
myself who grew up with a respectful
parenting kind of
way i still have my own traumas like
everybody has their traumas like trauma
is trauma right whether it's little it
affects you as a child in different ways
depending on each thing so yeah this is
like i love that you like talking to
your mom you're like no mom you're great
this is just like us learning from all
of our experiences and moving on as we
go with the next generation for sure and
my dad that that went with my dad too he
was breaking his own generational trauma
from the way that he was raised he
didn't have a great upbringing he had a
lot of trauma with it and he told
himself i'm not gonna do that i'm not
i'm gonna do it differently when i raise
my kids so it's similar type of thing
and i think that's so beautiful right
and that's why i think it's like
important that
that's why i like the term intentional
parenting and not like as opposed like
gentle parenting because
it's all about
doing everything with intention when you
have intention you have goals you have
you you know what you're doing and why
you're trying to do it because i feel
like you can you can still be the most
well intended parent and your stu your
child can still come out with a lot of
trauma because just because you're well
intended does not mean that you're
intentional
like you you could be doing this for
whatever you feel like is the greater
good of your child but if you're not
doing your research if you're not
educating yourself if you're not
learning and understanding and
connecting you know with your child it's
like
you cannot be 100 effectively
intentional
you'll just be doing your best and it's
like that's that's you can't
blame someone for that but in the same
token it's like that's
that's the difference and that's like
that's the disconnect with like a lot of
parents where it's like oh my god how
dare you have trauma i did my best with
you you know but it's like there's a
difference between doing your best and
being intentional
absolutely so there's something that you
said uh one of your like i wrote down
some of the things that you said in your
reels before that were really meaningful
to me um you said in order for us to
raise children who are accountable for
themselves we also have to be
accountable for ourselves and our
actions and you were stressing the
importance of like saying sorry because
i mean this is something i've talked
about before too in my
videos in the past about like if you
can't even say sorry yourself to your
kids when you've made a mistake how can
you expect them to say sorry to you
and this is kind of like what we were
just talking about like being held
holding yourself accountable right um
you want to expand on that a little bit
uh yeah
um
yeah i
i think that like
saying sorry to your kids
is one of those things where it's like
a new thing in a sense like in the past
it's it was like
i feel like when i i apologize to my
kids or people hear me apologize they're
talking about apologizing to my kids
it's like like foreign almost like
children don't deserve apologies
um
and i think that people are really
hopefully like
on a whole level people are coming to
the understanding that like
children are going to model what we do
before they do what we say
that is the biggest thing in parenting
like the big there could be one slogan
that's what it is i think when it comes
to parenting yeah literally and it's
like that's why
you can have parents that will
have certain actions and those children
will grow up with those same actions
it's like but i i told you better i
taught you better it's like but what
were you doing
what were you doing during that time so
that
i don't want to say it came natural to
me because like i said it's not
how i was brought up um
as what was normal but it was like once
i came to the realization of like
needing to apologize to my kids i think
it was like when they were like at that
age of like understanding an apology
like they were still pretty young and i
was like
yeah that makes total sense like how
like no wonder when i'm telling them
like say sorry and they're like sorry
there's no there's nothing there because
how do you understand
what a heartfelt apology is if you've
never received one
wow
yeah yeah i'm just like letting that
sink in yeah i think it's the best way
people look at me crazy when i tell them
like i don't force my children to say
sorry
and it can be tough because it's a hard
it's hard to not do it because you're
like trying so hard to get them to do
like you know so much of parenting is to
get them to raise them right right to
raise them well so that they are
empathetic beings that want to apologize
and they make a mistake but then you
find yourself in a situation where
you're trying to say sorry say sorry
then and then they finally do and you're
like oh wait that wasn't heartfelt at
all why did i do it like you mean it
yeah why did i do that why did i yeah
absolutely and it goes so much farther
when you're willing to say sorry i can't
even tell you how many times that just
by saying sorry to my child that you
could just see everything within them
relax their shoulders relax the love
just like pours in you can see them just
like almost like tears in their eyes
that they see like okay mommy like
she got it she did something i didn't
like and that hurt my feelings and like
she's she's holding space for me which
is just the same thing for your
relationships with your partner
you know like holding space for their
feelings and like being willing to
acknowledge when you've messed up
instead of pointing the finger at them
exactly yeah
exactly and another really important
thing i've seen you talk about recently
is about how you handle interactions
that you don't have forced you don't um
force interactions with strangers with
your kids and even though these are both
like small examples of things that we're
talking about they actually play a much
bigger role i think about how we view
our children how we handle parenting
with our children and raise them right
like so this is an individual experience
but it really holds a bigger picture i
think about like how we look at our kids
and it's really easy to just want to be
dictator right and that's kind of what
we were taught what the past generations
were taught i'm i'm the boss listen to
me do what i say exactly you know
and then we saw the damage that comes
from that right with the next generation
as we grew older and everything um but
can you explain how you respond when
your child doesn't like talk back talk
and respond to a stranger who's talking
to them so people can get a picture
yeah um
typically like
if
and i kind of talked about this a little
bit in the video so if like someone
comes up to my child and they say
something for one i think
i get a lot of negative responses with
this one and it's like kind of funny to
me because we grew up in that time of
like stranger danger but now like all of
a sudden it's like no it's rude not to
talk to strangers so it's like which one
is it
but
like i think people imagine that like
someone comes up and they're like hi and
i'm like go away and we just like snarl
at the person it's like
no we're still you know i'm still upbeat
you know i still smile you know
someone's speaking to my child um if
they'll say like oh hello or you know i
like your shoes or whatever then i'll
just make sure like did you hear them
you know he likes your shoes or did you
hear them say hi
and then if i see like they still don't
interact i'll just like oh you know
thank you so much or you know have a
great day you know whatever like i
respond on their behalf because like for
me it's just
it's not a big deal they don't know that
person you know why am i
why am i trying to
make a connection between
being rude or polite and speaking to
strangers like how do you
how do you teach that to a young child
and they'll and like it goes back to
modeling they'll see the way that you're
responding and over time that is how
they will respond instead of instead
because i was listening to an example i
remember i think i read it i remember if
i was listening to a podcast episode um
by like a parenting author i like or
something but she gave this example
where she's like imagine if you're at a
baby shower and it's your baby shower
and you're getting gifts right and you
open a gift and then um you know you
haven't said thank you yet or something
and then your mom is like say thank you
say thank you like in front of a big
group of people like how actually kind
of humiliating is that yeah awkward and
awkward and uncomfortable yeah all those
factors and so it's so pivotal to put
ourselves in their shoes and realize
that like they're they're much littler
than us they've only been on this earth
for you know a few short years and
they're just learning they're taking in
everything and instead of wanting to
like just stamp out any quote-unquote
imperfectness which is impossible
because we're not even perfect ourselves
we can just model that behavior and it
goes a long way it's tempting
to want to like try to get them to say
thank you or get them to acknowledge but
i do see the value in
in the modeling and respecting their
beingness and individuality and one time
um i had an experience like that when my
firstborn was still quite young he was
probably two and i had heard of this
notion i was con like of the not forcing
your kids to say thank you or sorry and
stuff and i was like still dabbling with
it but i wasn't able to fully commit and
i don't even know if i still am fully
committed to that like sometimes it's
very hard
um but i still but i like love that the
aspect of it
but um someone said something to him uh
my son that
a compliment right and i had and he
smiled so big and he didn't say thank
you yeah but he smiled so big and gave
like an outward reaction and i i think
at the time i said something like oh
yeah you want to say thank you elvis or
something and then the man was so sweet
he's like oh he already told me thank
you with his eyes
and i'm like wow what if we could just
start like just being less obsessed with
like this being the exact way and like
because body language and communication
goes a long way too
and
and looking at our kids in that way too
you know yeah so that that was a really
cool example to me of like just wanting
to make something perfect when really
it's like it already was perfect and
beautiful and i didn't have to go and
say that exactly yeah yeah and i mean
one of the a few things one thing i feel
like
we as adults well i don't say we
specifically but
there's like an obsession with like
children behaving a certain way or
acting a certain way and i feel like
it's if us as adults understand
how children work like developmentally
that they're still gonna be children
they're not going to be tiny adults like
so if we lower our expectations like if
we go through a grocery store and
there's a child crying and the mother
looks stressed and we just mind our
business or if we walk over and say like
are you okay you know like then there's
less pressure on the parent to feel like
my child needs to be perfect because 90
of why we feel that way is because
society makes us feel that way we feel
like we're going to be judged as parents
and so i feel like we have to like like
the
the part of the community that is not
parents or maybe like if we're out we're
not with our children we have to be able
to like
release that you know like make make
people feel okay to know like their
children are
children because like you said like
they're they're children they're going
to be children and they're still new to
the world and we expect for them to like
learn so much we have such high
expectations when they're so young and
it's like
how
like something that i
i was thinking about
maybe like a year ago and i was like
telling my husband about this like
concept i'm like dude children it's
literally like being in a foreign
country
that you've never been to before and
like you're you're still learning the
language you don't really understand the
interactions the culture is completely
different like imagine like going to a
country and then like walking up and
like
like kicking a stone and it's like say
schmacking and it's like
smogging
do i do that because if you kick a stone
it's disrespectful okay and it's like
there's no you don't like until you've
actually been in that country for like
long enough to understand why kicking a
stone is disrespectful and you need to
say schwagen that schmogen is just gonna
be like
someone told me to say that so that's
what i say you know so it's like i i i
feel like the modeling the response for
them plays such a big part because it's
literally it it lets them see everything
play out it's like it's a visual aid
instead of trying to force something
that's not authentic so they could go
through their whole life
you know like i mean maybe not their
whole life like hopefully eventually
they'll learn yeah but it's just like
why not let them develop their own
authenticity that doesn't mean we don't
still teach like we we can still be at
home and we still practice i still
practice with my kids okay you know when
someone gives you something say thank
you you know we still practice our
manners but
i don't put them in a spotlight when
they're out in public and something
happens i'm just it's just another
lesson yeah it's not a test yes and i
love what you said too about like um
helping others feel comfortable too and
not expecting perfection and it's a
perfect example with that stranger like
if i had known that that stranger
already felt like he had you know showed
appreciation just with his smile like i
would probably i wouldn't have said that
i wouldn't have said say thank you
because it was all about like oh i don't
want him to think that my kid's
ungrateful like like right it wasn't
even because i'm like i'm trying to make
sure he turns out this way it was it was
literally because we're so um influenced
by our culture and our society and how
we're going to be perceived so like we
have to like let that go and focus on
like their beingness and their
individuality absolutely yeah so i have
one more question for you what is some
is the something you hope for all
parents to be able to practice to help
raise this next generation of children
like if there was one thing that you
could hope
one thing oh gosh like because you know
it's like you said a lot of times like
you don't have time for read whole books
some of those listings might be like
driving somewhere because it's like
their only time to squeeze it in and
like what's this like like a practical
tool for someone like to get started
like what's it like i feel like that
slogan like even what we said something
like that i
i would say
i feel like every time i answer these
questions it's never like a slogan
it's never like the ideal answer but um
i i think that one thing that i would
love more parents to do that i feel like
is so especially like
like i mean i can't speak for other
countries in the whole but i would say
especially like in america or like in
the united states and i said because
like i like i said i went to belize
recently
and like it's just so different the
connections that parents have with their
children so different and one thing i
feel like we should focus on more is
like connection
having like when you have a connection
with someone
you analyze things differently
everything plays out differently and i
feel like because of like our culture
and
the united states and like it's like
fast-paced and go to work and make money
and go to work and come home and be
tired and cook dinner you know it's
really hard to foster connections like
we said earlier it's hard to foster
connection with your spouse and like if
you have more than one child like oh my
god you know so it's like making time to
like like for one to build a bond and
connection with that child and to like
taking
time even in moments of like frustration
even like in moments of like pressure to
really like dig into that connection and
connect with your child
and forget everything else and everybody
else and just focus on that little like
soul that you brought into the world i
feel like it changes
how you interact with them it changes
how angry you get at them or how you
perceive and that the video i posted the
other day is like a perfect example
because i never actually like told the
story of how it happened but i had so
many negative comments so i was just
like really quickly so
i was painting our travel trailer
and my three-year-old loves to paint
we've been going through this transition
we've been out of our home for two years
sorry two years oh my god two months
and that's like the only home he's ever
really known because we've been there
since he was a baby so he always asked
me he's always like mommy i want to go
back home i want to go back home and i'm
like i know but we're building a new
home we're building a train you know
getting him really excited about the the
little tiny home and so he loves
painting and so i was painting so he's
like really excited he wants to tell me
paint and me like my initial response is
like no you know because i'm like this
is just a big job like i don't want him
to make a mess you know so i'm like no
baby you know you can't help me pain so
he's mad at me
so he's like he comes back and he's like
i want my ball and i'm like
okay you know get your ball and i step
away for one second it was like the
minute i grabbed the ball i was like oh
no
and i ran back and he already like had
the paint like here i came there
painting and like i came it was like
like
you know how you respond to something
before you even have time to like think
about it so like as soon as i came back
in he was like look mommy i did it and i
was like kyle
yeah and he was like like he just got so
sad like i just saw in his eyes and like
he didn't even say like he didn't say
anything he just looked so sad like he
was about to cry
and i was like so innocent oh
and so like so yeah we i mean i still
went through i was like you know you
can't do that mommy told you you know
that you
can't do this and you need to listen you
know whatever the whole lecture whatever
i made him clean it up all that i had
him go back inside
but then i i prepped the area for him to
come back out and help me and
in people's minds i was like oh my god
where's the lesson all you taught him
was that if he disobeys you then you'll
just give him what he wants anyway like
you know but i'm like
you were not there to experience that
and
what
means mostly in that moment is that
connection with my child i connected
with my child in that moment and i saw
that my child was not trying to be
disrespectful no he was excited
and we're building a house and i've been
pumping him up for months about this
and he wanted to help me and it wasn't
like a oh let me hide the pain you know
like he was like showing me like look i
did it you know
i'm not gonna like shame him for that no
and how old is he too he's three three
oh my gosh
yes context matters age matters their
development matters like all that stuff
plays a big role even if it was an older
kid too though like like the intention
behind it intentions
so much
that's what i was trying to explain but
i was just like
if people focus on the connection with
their child instead of thinking like
what punishment is proper for this and
yeah what if they do this in society and
what will people think yeah just think
about like my child was trying to
connect with me in that moment no it was
not the best way to do it but a
disciplined action took place and i'm
still allowed to connect with my child
yeah even when they've misbehaved even
when they're getting on my last nerve
when they're throwing a tantrum i'm
still allowed to connect with my child
and that's the best thing that's what's
gonna help you get help them get through
it the best imagine if your partner same
situation with your partner right your
parents like well they did something
wrong so now i have to like shame them
shun them walk away from them because to
teach them a lesson
that makes you feel more distanced that
does not help you reconnect and help you
build a stronger relationship
yeah this is so good to end on that
because i totally agree with you yeah i
think if people focus more on that
connection the world would be a better
place i love that cool thank you so much
for being here where can people find you
um so oh god instagram
[Laughter]
is my main platform they call me mama
been it um we also have our family
instagram the bennett gang we also have
our tick tock
the bennett gang and then i have my
marriage tick tock mama pop up in it i
have way too many platforms and then my
website um is
mama bennett.com and that's where like
my book is and and
those other resources that i have great
i will put those links below for
everyone
and yeah thank you so much for being
here i had such a great time with you in
this conversation and i learned so much
i'm so inspired by you and thanks for
all that you do like boys thank you for
having me
[Music]
[Music]